s
mal changé.
- Est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est réaliste de croire
embarquer dans un système
comme ça et essa
de ne pas conduire quand
ils ont pris de l'alcool?
population embarquerait dans ça.
- C'est de trouver le
volontaire, c'est ça qui est
dur, je pense, de trouver
un volontaire qui ne boit pas
- La population a effectivement
adopté le projet et des
bénévoles, eh bien,
ils en ont trouvé.
En 1984, la premièesesesesesesee
dans la ville de Québec
avec la abababoration
du service de police.
(sonnerie)- Jean-Marie De Konin,
professeur de mathématiques
à l'Université Laval et aussi
entraîneur de natation,
a l'idée de reconduire
verre de trop dans leur propre
voiture pendant les s.s.s.s.
Il demande donc à ses nageurs
de servir de conducteurs., , , s
effectuent 463 raccompagnements
et accumulent des dons
de 20 000 $. Tout un succès!
- Alors, on va se porter à
l'écoute. Est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres stations qui sont
cédulés pour Opération Nez rouge
et qui sont en direction?
- L'Opération Nez roug
les mentalités sur la question
de l'alcool au volant.
GILLES LAMONTAGNE ancien lieut.-
gouv. du Québec (1984-1990)
causer l'accident possible.t t e
briser un foyer, parce que vous
n'êtes pas asseelelelelelelelelt
pour appeler Nez rouge.
- Le nombre d'accidents mortels
causés par l'alcool sont trop
fréquents. e e e e e e e e e e r
une opération d'ivresse au
volant. Est-ce que vous avez
consommé de la boisson
al- Opération Nez rouge, bonsoi!
- L'Opération prend alors de
l'expansion. Plusieurs villes
québécoises emboitent le pas.
qui offrent le service de
raccompagnement passe de 6 à
JEAN-MARIE DE KONINCK, président
fondateur, Opération Nez rouge
party quand quelqu'un était en
état de boisson, on di
"Une chance qu'il a sa voiture
pour rentrer chez lui,
il ne serait même pas
capable
Puis, on trouvait ça drôle.
- Fort heureusement, les
habitudes ont bien changé et
cette belle idée s'est propagée.
En 2019, l'Opération Nez rouge
rejoint 61 communautés au
- Ça a fait des petits
un peun n n n n n Europe,
surtout en Suisse.
- Chaque année je me réjouis
de faire Nez rouge, parce qu'on
ese e e e e e e e e e e e e e e.
- En raison de la pandémie,
l'Opération Nez rouge a
considérablement réduit02020202.
Mais cette année
tout revient à la normale.
Il semble y avoir un intérêt
important de la part de la
co
et tout, et aussi des bénévoles.
- Dans chacune d
les sommes recueillies servent
aussi à financer de nombreuses
activités pour les a a a a a a .
- Au'e'e'e'e'e'e'est une
centaine d'organismes à but
non lu
l'Opération Nez rouge sur leur
territoire et qui pr
totalement des retombées
financières de
- Mais avant tout,
il ne faut pas l'oublier,
l'Opération Nez rouge
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,ioioioioa